all right a man suspected of killing an
iowa college student and hiding her body
in a cornfield is due in court today
24-year old christian bikina rivera is
being charged with the first-degree
murder of Mollie Tibbets Rivera is an
undocumented immigrant who lived near
Tibbets she disappeared on July 18th
while out for a jog police believe they
have found her body Adriana Diaz is in
pouchette County Jail in Montezuma Iowa
Adriana good morning good morning behind
me is where Christian by Hannah Rivera
is being held on 1 million dollars bail
if convicted he faces life in prison
without parole
police sifted through more than 4,000
tips but they say it was home
surveillance video that was a critical
piece of evidence that helped them crack
the case a body was discovered early
this morning we believe it to be the
body of Mollie Tibbles the search for
20-year old Molly Tibbets came to a
somber and Tuesday in a cornfield off
this dirt road about 12 miles from where
she went missing
Christian Mahina Rivera aged 24 has been
charged with murder in the first degree
the big break came over a week ago when
investigators obtained surveillance
video showing Tibbets jogging they
noticed a black Chevy Malibu following
her police traced the car to Rivera and
brought him in for questioning Monday he
tells us that he sees Molly running he
actually tells us that he ran alongside
of her or behind her Rivera says Tibbets
threatened to call police
she took off running he in turn chased
her down and then he tells us that at
some point time he blacks out in the
affidavit
police say Rivera told them when he came
to he found Tibbets body in his trunk
and noticed blood on the side of her
head he dragged Tippit's on foot to a
secluded location in a cornfield after
the interview police say Rivera guided
them to that location from memory
investigators have been searching this
area for weeks why was she not found
before there were corn stalks placed
over the top of her
so we just weren't able to locate her
police didn't definitively save Rivera
and Tibbets were strangers he tells us
that he had seen her before but beyond
that I won't be able to say any more
last night President Trump suggested the
murder could have been prevented you
heard about today with the illegal alien
coming in very sadly from Mexico and you
saw what happened to that incredible
beautiful young woman should have never
happened
Rivera who's lived in the area four to
seven years worked at a nearby dairy
farm that's owned by the family of a
local Republican leader named Craig
Lange in a statement the farm said
Rivera passed a government screening
that deemed him eligible to work
Molly Tippit's family isn't commenting
at this time but we saw them here
outside at the police briefing while the
suspect was being held inside such a
tragic end to a story that really
captivated at the entire country Adriana
thank you
the Colorado man accused of killing his
pregnant wife and two young daughter
showed no emotion at court hearing on
the charges Christopher Watts Warren
orange jumpsuit and shackles yesterday
as a judge told him he was charged with
nine felonies including first-degree
murder Watts did not enter a plea newly
released video shows the oil drums where
investigators found the girl's bodies
last week their mother's body was found
nearby buried in a shallow grave
investigators say they also found a
bedsheet that matched others in the
Watts home prosecutors will decide in
the next two months if they will seek
the death penalty